so what should we think of the story was
we should say at the outset that not
every tragedy has obvious lessons we are
hesitant to draw
quick and dirty political conclusions
particularly partisan ones from
something bad that happened not every
mudslide in sri lanka or cyclone in ohio
is the result of climate change
fair
but it's still interesting to know a lot
more about the man who apparently
committed this crime frank james who was
he what did he think well it turns out
that for years frank james posted black
supremacist rants on his youtube channel
for all to see some of these videos date
back to 2013 and continue to very
recently he uploaded within the last few
days
overnight the journalist andy noe
unearthed a number of these posts you
can go find them online we're not going
to show them to you but we want to read
you some expert excerpts so you have
some idea of what this man was thinking
in one video he posted to youtube james
declares that quote white people and
black people as we call ourselves should
not have any contact with each other
blacks and whites so-called should not
even be in the same hemisphere
james seemed especially enraged that
judge kintanji brown jackson joe biden's
supreme court pick had married a white
man quote i had no idea that she would
be married to a white man yeah our black
sister supreme court justice power to
the people is married to an effing white
man
in other posts james called for violence
against people on the basis of their
skin color in one video james says for
example that quote the white mfrs that i
want to kill you know i really want to
kill them because they're white
pretty direct about his feelings on that
on facebook he posted a meme that said
quote oh black jesus please kill all the
whities
why was he so angry will james explain
that himself quote the vast majority of
people white mfrs are racist
he'd seen that on cnn and he believed it
there were signs long before the
shooting yesterday that james was
dangerous that he might act out against
other people in one instance james
filmed himself shouting racial epithets
of people on the street quote f you and
your white ass too you mfr and to throw
that in for good luck i don't listen
yeah white racist m effort they do exist
they do effing exist we could go on and
on and on he attacks asians too
disgusting
so this guy was a racist he was not a
white supremacist and that might
surprise you because joe biden and some
of the shills you work for him including
the attorney general and the head of dhs
have told us again and again and again
and the new york times has confirmed
this again and again and again
that white supremacists right-wing trump
voters are the number one terror threat
in the united states of america here's
biden
we must confront and defeat political
extremism
white supremacy and domestic terrorism
white supremacy domestic terrorism
that we must confront and we will defeat
according to the united states
intelligence community domestic
terrorism from white supremacists
is the most lethal terrorist threat in
the homeland
what a liar he is yeah there are racists
of all colors in this country but white
supremacy is not the main threat we face
racial animus of all kinds is not the
main threat we face and in fact since
joe biden took office there has not been
a single deadly attack by a white
supremacist or a q anon shaman
at the same time since joe biden took
office a blm supporter rammed his car
into a barricade at the capitol and
murdered a police officer then another
blm's reporter ran over dozens of people
including children at a christmas parade
in wisconsin in waukesha
killing six people many more were maimed
most recently a blm supporter and by the
way an honoree of the barack obama
foundation tried to assassinate a
mayoral candidate in kentucky again most
people who commit acts of violence like
this are mentally ill
so there isn't always an obvious
political lesson but if you take three
steps back maybe if the entire news
media tells you every day of your life
that america hates you because of your
skin color
you might respond to that at a certain
point
why wouldn't you why wouldn't we see
more crimes like this
they're being abetted and effectively
encouraged by the bide administration
and the american news media obviously
and is bad for everybody of all colors
showing race hatred suspicion
anxiety is terrible for the country and
they're doing it every single day
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight